welcome to this video a 15 minute game
and I'm playing a citizen Dane from
Denmark yeah this does make some sense
so let's think about this may be a
Sicilian mixing up lines I could play
the classical song in with 96 that's not
so popular nowadays on the highest level
but for for normal players it's
certainly still a very good line yeah
Bishop c4 is the so-called souls in
variation an interesting way to play
it's a bit of a middle of road approach
it's not super sharp still ambitious old
favorite of bobby fischer's he always
played the Bishop c4 against all types
of Sicilians the night of the classical
here okay I'm just completing my
development and then see how to get some
counter play okay is playing a quick a
form without even being provoked to that
by a thick by a 60 came maybe maybe a
normal-looking look like this intending
to capture and play Bishop c6
okay yeah he might retreat the night to
be three but I have night a five against
that yeah besides Bishop d7 there also
was Knight takes e4 the pseudo sacrifice
but this is very young yeah a very young
dry option so I didn't go for that ok
interesting now I mean ok Bishop takes
is certainly ok but hmm yeah I wonder if
pawn takes as a move it certainly
certainly is not bad that much is clear
and i'm a bit tempted to play that
because he also has played a four and
has weakened the Queen side of it yeah
looks like rook v8 would quickly attack
the beep horn for example ok I'm doing
that it's not not clear what what's
better him at least I'm not sure Bishop
takes also wasn't bad attacking e-form
but this is on the one hand doing
something on the queenside and also
allowing to play d 5
yeah Luke be eight yeah maybe just
rotate hmm yeah but I wasn't sure about
bishop 87 though okay well I could have
probably take an army to not much danger
that the ruckus I'm going to be captured
or let's say not captured but trapped
okay maybe Queen am attacking the
inducer knight on c3 intending to
continue with d5 grabbing the center
yeah that's not bad yeah now that's 95
threatened so I better we treat the
Queen but on c7 I should be better off
than on d 8 so 47 I'm actually preparing
to play d 5 at the right mode okay so d
5 or not yeah probably d5
ok very important decision now what is
happening in the center what can take on
d5 he can just stay put a form many
moves k Queen f3 the idea of bishop d6
is to put it on e5 centralizing
preventing a 45 I'm going to money 5
there are many additional ideas with the
long diagonal nicely controlled while
also had maybe have to the idea to play
a Bishop f4 awesome I think this this
does make some sense came Bishop g5 is
not really a move that I'm expected
that's really tricky already what are
you doing with your night if you which I
probably grab the rook yeah probably
Bishop detune which is not exactly great
for white retreating but it seems to be
the best move relatively speaking okay
well you can suddenly if you know my my
channel can certainly guess what I'm
thinking about this one I mean okay
maybe it was them there wasn't anything
better really but with black being
better in the center and having the
power bishops it's already getting very
very problematic and in fact it's a
concrete problem this Bishop is
attacking the knight and yeah how do you
actually handle this attack if you move
it out take the Lucani one winning an
exchange Bishop e2 for example I have
four moves like Queen a five
yeah Bishop takes f6 was not him not
playable at all i think he needed to
retreat to d2 which wasn't something
something great but at least i think it
didn't loss I didn't lose them outright
which is the case here white really has
no movie em at least I don't see it
yeah probably you need to just continue
being an exchange dow down 92 or
something I mean it's just an exchange
but other moves are not really any
better yeah I think up to here this was
probably not the most testing set up
ever but certainly okay for white and
starting here white is going astray a
bit normal I think would be you two to
retreat the sea for Bishop maybe to be 3
or a 2 g-m by okay is played in five so
Bishop iam yeah I can actually take it I
mean he needs to sacrifice another piece
on age seven so no reason to not take
the night
check yeah so it's a piece a piece form
for just the h-bond now the best the
best way very often to use the pieces to
to use an extra piece I mean is to
figure out where exactly this piece
should be positioned and here Bishop to
e4 comes to mind so I try to get this in
quickly okay the check first is not
really oops Queen B 6 I mean does not
really help much but okay this is a very
very good piece on e4 okay I could trade
queens which is not bad at all i can
take c2 c2 would actually take away the
defender of the beep and so I guess
that's that's a good idea so that may be
rocked xb3 can be played quickly okay
now come on keep it simple this
exchanges queens and after that they're
really nice Riza yes there's really
absolutely zero chances to get something
against my king yeah it really went
downhill relatively quickly here I think
something like Bishop to be three or
Bishop a to something like that should
be ok it's not great but certainly
certainly play mo yan TM this is
probably shouldn't lead to two big
problems but I think it's a step in the
wrong direction especially with a for
being plagued play to there are some
weaknesses here and we see that quickly
the rook gets positioned here still
nothing going on here I thought actually
Bishop a7 could be a move I only only at
the end of my thought process I got this
in mind I actually thought that this
could be interesting ah interesting yep
black has an excellent response and
black is winning
very nice young b3 and kun 85 yeah not
great maybe Queen a 5v5 was also
possible okay but it does not hurt my
chance as much yeah here it is very
important I think Queen f3 should be six
black as comfortable here but after
Bishop g5 it gets very very tricky
already and now absolutely Bishop d2 is
the only move everything else i think is
losing material so he really has to drop
back to the two it's tough to do we
basically returning to the place where
you come from but sometimes it must be
done yeah this is just a straight away
straight away losing check with black
being just two peas up for for no
compensation whatsoever yeah still a
line that can be recommended for white
if you I just stood in an ambitious line
against the classical Bishop c4 in a way
yeah well forgotten people really only
look at the rosen nowadays with Bishop
g5 here and so a bishop see form can be
an interesting option okay I hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching